[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning thank you all for being
here
from my right let me introduce who I
have with me and then acknowledge some
special friends to my right is Gareth
Rhodes who has been he works with the
Department of Financial Services but
he's been working with us in Albany
during this coronavirus pandemic to my
left Melissa DeRosa was secretary to the
governor to her left
Robert mihika who is the state budget
director he doesn't smile much in
nowadays because the state budget is not
in great shape but when the federal
government does the right thing and
gives us funding we expect that he's
gonna smile that big smile again it's a
pleasure to be in Rochester with so many
of my friends who have done such great
work for the state former lieutenant
governor Bob Duffy who worked with me
when we first got started and has done
great work for the entire state of New
York Danny Wegman pleasure to be with
you Wenk means is a great New York
corporation and then he's a great civic
leader and they've been very helpful
through this situation also thank you
for allowing us to do the antibody
testing at Wegmans that's been very very
helpful and we thank you for everything
you've done
and Nicole Wegman thank you pleasure
thank you for being on our New York
forward advisory board to help us going
forward and find our way through this
let's give you an update on where we are
today the total number of
hospitalizations is down you see that
curve coming down you see that mountain
that we went up now we're on the other
side of the mountain you start to see
the shape of the mountain unfortunately
the decline from the mountain is not as
steep as the incline right and the big
question for us in New York and and
every state of course the nation has
been
how fast and how low does that decline
go right how fast does the decline
actually happen and what is the lowest
level that the decline will reach
unfortunately you see that we were
shaped we were hoping for a quick up
plateau at the top which is what they
talked about but a fast decline you see
the decline is again not as steep as the
incline but it is a decline and that's
good news then that change in total
hospitalizations is is down and that
change in intubations is down and that's
always good news when a person is it
intubated roughly 80% of the times there
is not a good outcome so the fact that
the intubations is down is a good is
good news and then the other end is how
many new cases are coming in the door
every day how many new diagnoses in
kovat cases and that number is also
declining so not only are the number of
people in hospitals coming down but the
number of new cases coming in the door
is down and that's good news because it
had plateaued at about 900 statewide for
a few days but this number is is down at
700 and that's a good number I would
take this with a grain of salt as they
say because this is reporting from
yesterday which was a Sunday and
sometimes we get different results on
the weekend remember this whole
reporting system is just been put in
place this never happened before
this is now every hospital in the state
reporting every day for the first time
so it's a plus or minus across the board
this is the number that haunts me every
day and this number is not declining any
nearly as fast as we would like to see
it decline still 226 PETA New Yorkers
who passed away and so we don't become
immune we talk about these numbers
it's 226 families right that's 226 wives
or brothers or sisters or children that
are now suffering the loss of a loved
one so that we remember them in our
thoughts and our prayers people are all
talking about reopening which we should
be talking about this is not a
sustainable situation close down
everything close down the economy lock
yourself in the home you can do it for a
short period of time but you can't do it
forever but reopening is more difficult
than the closed down the closed down was
relatively simple right you go into the
basement you throw the big power switch
and everything just goes down close the
businesses stay at home it was a blunt
operation and one that was done all
across the country just stop everything
now when you go to restart the reopening
now knowing what we know it's more
nuanced you have to be more careful and
again no one has done this before no one
has been here before so first start by
learning the lessons that we did learn
through this experience and second let's
be smart about what we do and I get the
emotion and I get the impatience and I
get the anxiety we all feel it when I
say this situation was unsustainable its
unsustainable on many levels its
unsustainable economically its
unsustainable personally a lot of
anxiety is now all through our community
we see it in increased alcoholism
increased substance abuse increased
domestic violence so this is a very very
difficult period and people want to move
on yes
but let's be smart about what we do and
let's learn the lessons one of the
lessons is we have never been here
before
and we didn't really know what was going
on
CDC releases a report and the last week
that says the virus was actually coming
to the East Coast from Europe everybody
was looking at China for all those
months trying to turn a China China yeah
China was last November December the
virus migrated from China while we were
all staring at China and went to Europe
and the strain that came to the United
States came from Europe we had people in
the airports stopping people from China
testing people from China the federal
government did a lot of testing a lot of
screening people getting off planes from
China yeah but me and other people from
Europe were walking right past them and
that's where the strain came from that
was infecting this area and that's what
the CDC just learned last week and this
is going back to February right on one
of the most study topics ever again just
learn the lessons of what happened you
now add that piece of information on the
Europe trips and then you see the number
of flights that came from Europe during
that time where they landed and now you
it explains why you've seen the outbreak
in Chicago that you've seen why you've
seen the number of cases in New York
because yes the flights were landing
here people were coming from Italy and
UK and from European countries and
nobody thought to screen them nobody was
on guard and you add that to the density
of New York especially in New York City
and that virus just took off okay we
didn't know we didn't know now we do we
also can look back in history you look
at that 1918 flu pen
that they talk about the places that
opened too soon
so that flew come right back and by the
way that flew was not one wave that was
three waves first wave second way of
third wave second wave was worse than
the first wave and you see watch the
other countries that went through this
before us right we're not the first one
down the chute there were other
countries that went down before us you
see they wanted to reopen also they were
feeling the pressure on reopening and
you study those cases and you see that
you've reopened too soon or you reopen
unintelligently and you can then have an
immediate backlash and that's not
speculation that is looking at other
countries and look at what what has
happened around the world and then you
talk to the experts who know listen to
what they're saying
dr. pouchy who i think is one of the
best voices and minds on this dr. Falchi
has been through this in in different
iterations he was one of the pioneers on
the HIV virus and AIDS and he says we
could be in for a bad fall and a bad
winter could be why cuz he doesn't know
he's not sure but could be for a bad
fall or bad winter okay so put all of
this in the in the equation and then
also acknowledge and actualize that the
truth is that nobody knows what happens
next and when it happens well how can
that be that nobody knows we're so
sophisticated we have so much
intelligence we have so many experts
this is the United States of America how
can it be that no one knows because no
one knows I speak to the best experts
globally globally and nobody can tell
you for sure now at
spirts we look to experts and we expect
them to know so we push them to know
answer the question tell me when what's
going to happen in September what's
going to happen in December sometimes
the answer is I don't know sometimes
that's the honest answer I was talking
to my daughter's last night and they
said you know you say at your briefings
I don't know how can you say that first
I'm not really sure they watch my
briefings but they're right sometimes I
say I don't know why because I don't
know and if you don't know say you don't
know and I speak again to the best minds
in this country the best minds around
the globe and they don't know so if you
don't know say you don't know it doesn't
mean you're not smart no reason to get
defensive I don't know when you know
what you don't know and admit it it will
actually keep you safe my daughters
don't quite agree with this yet but I
haven't given up on the concept know
what you don't know know when you don't
know what the future holds you can be
safe because then you can prepare for
different possibilities and that's where
we are we don't know but we will be
prepared for all possibilities so
reopening chart a course with the best
information you have learning from the
lessons you have but be able to correct
that course depending on what happens
which means don't act emotionally don't
act because I feel this I feel that
because someone said well other states
are opening so we'll you must be able to
open if other states are open if we get
the anecdotal forget the atmospherics
forget the environment don't forget the
emotional look at the data look at the
measurements look at the science follow
the facts and that's what we've done
here from day one this is no gut
instinct this is look at the data look
at their science
look at the metrics move forward
measuring what you can and what you know
and then be prepared to adjust well I
want specificity I want to know for sure
you don't but there's liberation in
knowing that so let's do this
intelligently based on metrics and we'll
see what happens and we'll adjust to
whatever happens well what does that
mean our metrics you can measure this
and we have to measure this you look at
that percentage and the rate of
hospitalizations which we have right
that's the chart that goes up and down
you watch that hospitalization rate do
your diagnostic testing so you know how
many people are testing positive and you
can watch that rate going up or down or
flat do the contract tracing so after
the testing you follow up and you do
that contact tracing and you are then
reducing the infection spread by
isolating the positives if you do those
things you will control the rate of
transmission of the virus which is
everything
nobody says you're going to eliminate
the virus in the short-term no body but
you can control the rate of transmission
and if you can control the rate of
transmission you can control the rate of
transmission from becoming an outbreak
or an epidemic or overwhelming your
public health system that is the best
you can do so control the rate of
transmission to what they call one point
one or less one point one is every
person infects one point one other
people more than one other person if
you're doing that that is an outbreak
that means it's going to increase
exponentially and it's going to be out
of control as long as your rate of
transmission is manageable and low then
reopen your businesses and reopen the
businesses in phases
so you're increasing that activity level
while you're watching the rate of
transmission rate of transmission goes
up stop the reopening close the valve
close the valve right away so reopen
businesses do it in phases and watch
that rate of transmission it gets over
one point one stop everything
immediately that's where the other
countries wound up they started to
reopen they exceeded the one point one
it became an outbreak again they had to
slow down rather than starting and
stopping you'd rather have a controlled
start so you don't have to stop right
and that's what you learn from the other
countries you reopen too fast then you
have to stop and nobody wants to have
gone through all of this and then start
just to stop again well how does that
happen first of all it's not going to
happen statewide this state has
different regions which are in much
different situations than other regions
in this state and rather than wait for
the whole state to be ready reopen on a
regional basis if upstate has to wait
for downstate to be ready they're gonna
be waiting a long time
so analyze the situation on a regional
basis okay and you look at a region on
four measures the number of new
infections your health care capacity if
the infections goes too high you
overwhelm your health system now your
Italy with people on Gurney's in the
hallway because your hospital system
can't handle it do your diagnostic
testing so you're seeing how the
infection is increasing or decreasing
and do the contact tracing have that
system in place so when you test then
you find a positive you trace the
contacts from that positive person and
you're isolating them too
down the rate and you do that on a
regional basis that system has to be in
place for a regional basis how do you
start when can I start
reopening we look at guidelines from the
CDC which say a region has to have at
least 14 days of decline in total
hospitalizations and death on a
three-day rolling average so you take a
3 day average you have to have 14 days
of decline
you can't have more than 15 new total
cases or 5 new deaths on a three day
rolling average this is telling you that
you're basically at a plateau level that
you can actually start to reopen then
you're watching the rate of infection
and the spread of the infection and the
benchmark there is fewer than two new
covered patients per 100,000 residents
right it's based on your population to
account for the variants in the
different sizes of regions across the
state
then anticipate protect yourself from
all possibilities well what if we have a
surge again never fill your hospitals to
more than 70 percent capacity leave 30
percent in case you have a surge
remember this virus is tricky the rate
of infection per a person who gets
infected today shows up in the hospital
10 days from today or two weeks from
today
so that infection rate goes up you don't
feel it for two weeks there's a lag to
it you want to make sure you have 30
percent of the hospital beds available
in case you have that surge also learn
the lessons from before every hospital
has to have 90 days of PP
for that hospital at the rate that they
have been using it during covert we
cannot have another mad scramble where
nurses and doctors don't have downs and
masks etc because the hospitals don't
have the necessary stockpile so make
sure every hospital has the stockpile on
the testing we have done really
remarkable work on testing 1 million New
Yorkers have now been tested believe it
or not
and the CDC coronavirus task force for
the White House recommends that for a
region to reopen you have 30 tests for
every 1000 residents ready to go so what
testing capacity do we need for a region
to reopen you have to be prepared to do
30 tests for every 1000 residents New
York is doing more tests than any
country in the state by far New York is
doing more tests than any country on the
globe per capita so we're way ahead and
testing but it doesn't matter what we're
doing statewide to open a region that
region has to have a testing capacity of
30 per 1000 the National Guard has been
doing a great job for us in putting
together testing kits and distributing
testing kits and we want to thank them
very much but we have to have those
tests and we have to have what they call
tracers contact tracers in place and
Mayor Bloomberg has been very helpful
former mayor of New York City in putting
together this tracing system this has
never existed before on the scale a
group of people who literally trace
contacts from a person who's positive
who did you have dinner with last night
who did you have dinner with two nights
ago who might you have been in contact
with
and then contacting those people to say
do you have any symptoms if you do you
should know you were with John Smith
John Smith tested positive he said he
went to dinner with you you should be on
alert that old tracing system has never
been done not only in this state but in
this country so this that all has to be
set up and it has to be done once that
is all done then you can talk about
reopening businesses well which
businesses do we open first you open
businesses first that are most essential
and pose the lowest risk okay most
essential and the lowest risk phase one
we're talking about construction
manufacturing and select retail with
curbside pickup they are the most
essential with the lowest risk second
phase professional services retail
administrative support real estate third
phase restaurant food services
accommodation fourth arts entertainment
recreation education
remember density is not your friend here
large gatherings are not your friend
that's where the virus tends to spread
that's why those situations would be
down at the end and then we need
businesses to also really imagine how
they're going to do business and get
ready to protect their workforce to
change their physical environment to the
extent they need to and to change their
processes to make sure people can
socially distance people remain at a
safe in a safe environment and that's
going to be up to businesses to come up
with ways to reconfigure their workplace
and their processes to make this work
and that's business by business
government can say these are the
standards but a business is going to
have to
you're out how to do that when you look
at the state there are some regions that
right now by the numbers pose a lower
risk some that pose a higher risk we can
tell you by region right now of those
criteria that we went through which ones
are in place for which region so which
ones have the right hospitalization the
right testing regimen the right contract
contact tracing regimen and which ones
still have work to do in those areas and
this is going to be region by region and
each region has to put together the
leaders in those respective areas who
put together this system and monitor
this system literally on a daily basis
so they're getting all that import all
those specifics all that data and then
day by day they're making a decision as
to how to proceed with reopening based
on the data based on the facts and
that'll be a little different for every
region in the state May 15th is when the
statewide pause order PA USC not PA WS
the pause order the pause order was
stopped all businesses stay at home that
expires on May 15th May 15th regions can
start to reopen and do their own
analysis but these are the facts that
they have to have in place to do it
start now don't wait to May 15th
don't call me up on May 15th and say
well the pause order expired
I want to open because I'm gonna ask you
the questions I just asked I just
presented do you have a healthcare
system in place is your health system
ready can your hospitals handle it the
have testing in place the apt racing in
place have you talked to the businesses
about how they're going to reopen so we
have a couple of weeks but the this is
what local leaders this is what a
community has to deal with to reopen
safely and intelligently in my opinion
this can't just be we want to get out of
the house we're going No
let's be smart let's be intelligent
let's learn from the past let's do it
based on facts you know we are at a
different time in place government is
fundamentally in a different position
than it was just a couple of months ago
this is for real now right government
politics it's not about optics it's not
about celebrities not about press
releases it's not about what I put on
Instagram yesterday this is about
government leaders performance their
expertise this is a situation where
their competence and their ability can
be the difference between life and death
literally and what the governments have
done federal state local what we've done
in this state has literally saved lives
we reduced all the projected
hospitalization rates dramatically by
about a hundred thousand New Yorkers 100
thousand fewer New Yorkers were
hospitalized than they predicted 100,000
think about that if we had 100,000 more
people in our hospital system first of
all our hospital system would have
collapsed
if the projections were true if we
didn't change those projections and we
literally saved lives how many of those
100,000 would have been hospitalized and
would have died so we've done great work
at a tremendous cost and tremendous
hardship but we've done great work
we just have to remain vigilant and
smart and competent going forward and
that's what New York tough means New
York tough means we're tough but we're
smart with discipline we're unified and
we are loving and it's the love of
community and love of each other and
respect for each other which is what has
gotten us through this and will continue
to thank you very much for taking the
time to be here thank you for the social
distancing questions for myself or any
of my colleagues mask-wearing I said
look I believe this is the this is a
time for sort of honest straightforward
talk I said that I think it's
disrespectful of people not to wear
masks I mean think about it you see all
these commercials on TV we thank you to
our heroes thank you to the nurses thank
you to the doctors thank you to the
Transit workers thank you to the police
officers and we should be thankful right
they went to work so all of us could
stay safe and go home the look the least
gratitude you can show is at least wear
the mask so you don't infect more people
who place more of a burden on the
hospitals and the nurses and the doctors
who were all saying thank you for your
great service you really want to say
thank you then respect them and respect
their job and wear the mask so you don't
infect people well I don't want to wear
a mask it's not that big a deal and by
the way you don't wear a mask for
yourself you wear a mask to protect me I
wear a mask to protect you we owe each
other a certain amount of reasonableness
and respect in society and I owe you
that level of respect that if I'm sick I
should wear a mask
local governments have the ability to
enforce and to penalize that's up to
local governments but do I think local
government should be enforcing it and
should there be sanctions yes yes
because it is a public health emergency
you know this is not just do me a favor
this is a public health emergency and
it's a statewide order that I put in
place that I'm proud of and local
governments have the responsibility to
enforce it and part of their right the
illegal right is they can have a penalty
or a sanction that they impose so
Rochester can have one penalty you know
you can be appropriate to the to the
community New York cities in a different
situation but yeah I think local
government should enforce it and I think
there should be a penalty because you
could literally literally kill someone
you could literally kill someone because
you didn't want to wear a mask I mean
how how cruel and irresponsible would
that be yes yes you don't have to worry
no one said wear a mask all the time
right wear a mask if you may be in a
situation where you can't socially
distance you go for a walk in the woods
you don't have to be wearing a mask you
come to a point even for you from your
walk in the woods where you're going to
be in a parking lot or there's an
entrance and an exit and you may run
into other people wear the mask you can
have the mask down when you're walking
in the woods but now you see someone
coming the other way I'm gonna pass by
the other person you put the mask on I
mean it's it's the least that we can do
right everyone is killing themselves
people are working 24 hours a day show
some respect
so some basic modicum of respect
yeah putting putting all of these new
systems in place is an incredible task
and you know Society now we have a
temptation to blame well who's to blame
who's to blame nobody is to blame that
we don't have testing capacity for
millions of Americans we've never done
this before
our testing system was basically for the
flu test or strep or some other blood
test when the doctor would send you to a
lab to get a blood test we never had a
testing system in this nation that could
do this volume so this whole thing is
the scramble and it was a scramble
between the federal government in the
States who's supposed to do it who's
responsible I had a good meeting with
the president a while back where we sat
down and we said look the states
controlled the labs we have about 300
labs in in New York State we regulate
them the state should be responsible for
what they can do and we need the federal
government to help where they can the
supply chain issue of reagents
manufacturing etc that is an
international supply chain ironically so
much of this stuff comes from China it's
like incredible on the testing the
reagents the chemicals as well as the
PPE when we were looking for masks and
gowns everything was in China but the
federal government has assumed the
responsibility of that international
supply chain the reagents etc this
states sort of take over at the state
line but that supply has increased and
we are distributing it and as you saw
we're doing more testing than any other
state or any other country per capita so
we're coming online very very quickly
but we still have more to do
since we'll be reopening for the rest of
the school year and I spoke to local
yeah they're going to get guidance on
what the what plan they need to reopen
schools which is basically the analog to
what a business needs right I want to
reopen my manufacturing company okay how
do you do it and keep people six feet
apart how do you do it in the cafeteria
how do you do it in the transport
how do you run your business in a way
that's going to now meet the social
distancing guidelines same thing for a
school part of the issue for school was
just the the gatherings in the school
you have 25 students in a class how do
you put 25 students in a class in their
6 feet apart I mean look at this space
right even these press conferences you
need for 20 people you need you know a
tremendous sized room how how would you
do that in the school how do you
socially distance students do you need
more classrooms which means they need
more teachers how do you serve lunch
what do you do about the bus how do you
keep fewer students on the bus so those
kinds of details have to be in the
reopening plan they'll get guidance on
that but it's going to be easier said
than done especially for a school
because think about the problem is the
gathering a school is a gathering that's
what it is
yeah look I get the whole liber8
movement there's no reason for a closing
of anything just open everything up and
let everybody go do whatever they want
to do I get that argument I hear it I
understand it I'm sympathetic to it you
know everybody wants out I also know the
facts of what has happened to the places
have who have done that and what you
suggest that was all those countries
that saw saw a spike in the number of
cases right afterwards saw a spike in
the infection rate sort of spike in the
hospitalizations or spike in the number
of deaths and I would like to see as few
New Yorkers pass away as possible so yes
people want to get out on the other hand
we want to do it in a responsible way
and that's the whole question
you know 80 and 90% of us don't get the
coronavirus nobody has gotten the
coronavirus before some people say well
this is like a flu yeah it's not like a
flu even eighty ninety percent of us
don't get the flu right but this is a
different beast that we're dealing with
and we learned that the hard way
you don't hear anyone saying anymore
this is like the flu right that was back
in January February that was before we
had 18,000 people in our hospitals in
New York this is not a flu let's take
one more yes
[Music]
yeah this is a national problem we have
unemployment systems states run the
unemployment system in this case we have
a lot of federal benefits that are
running through the unemployment system
the unemployment system was set up with
phone operators and a website to handle
like thousands of calls thousands of
input we now have millions of inputs it
is overwhelmed every state unemployment
website office etc I talked to all the
governor's on these conference calls
they're all struggling to deal with a
number of unemployment claims federal
government then just passed a piece of
legislation several weeks ago that had
additional benefits for people which
then required new signups and then it
broke more people to the websites etc we
have hired over 3,000 people to actually
run our unemployment service our website
and to handle the telephones 3,000
people which is just incredible just for
the unemployment line and we've made
great progress there is still for some
people a delay because you do have to
document and certify that the person is
eligible you know just can't be just if
somebody calls up and you Bob Duffy
calls and say okay and you send them a
check federal law and common sense
requires that you affirm certain
information the good news is even if
there's a delay on the website it
doesn't cost you any money when you get
the check the check is from the date of
your eligibility even though the website
can be a pain in the neck to deal with
but I'll ask Melissa
DeRosa who has been overseeing this if
she has an update on the unemployment
say those people who have pending status
and this is actually very important in
commissioner Reardon is going to do a
call later today to brief out on the
latest what we found in the last several
days is that a lot of the people who are
in pending
have not gone on and certified their
unemployment status which is a separate
process from going through the
application so you file the application
you do the phonecall you process through
but then you have to go into the website
into your account and certify that
you're unemployed and that's something
you have to do every week by Saturday so
you can either do it on your website
account or you can call there's two
separate numbers for unemployment
insurance it's eight eight eight five
eight one five eight one two and four
pandemic unemployment insurance it's
eight three three three two four OH
three six six and you have to do that
every single week and certify that you
are still unemployed and eligible to
work and then they process that
information so we sent out 90,000 emails
over the weekend to a batch of people we
identified that we're stuck in that
pending status because of that and as I
said Commissioner Reardon is gonna be
doing a more detailed call this
afternoon to continue to get this
information out to the public but that
is the number one thing that I would
recommend to those people who are still
sitting in pending status yes
priority status and just to punctuate
one other thing the governor said about
the flu the one big difference between
corona virus and the flu is that the flu
has a vaccine so for those people who
are still making that comparison I'd
like you to consider that
but you don't know what on the floor
vexing a coronavirus you don't know what
percent is gonna wind up getting it
nobody does and the experts don't know
either well that's not true
but yeah let's say it is true that the
overwhelming number of people who get it
don't die yeah okay yeah that's fine
unless you're the person who dies then
it's not so funny
yeah the the nursing homes have seen in
many ways the most intense issue here
and when you think about where this even
started it started in a nursing home in
Washington of Washington the vulnerable
population our senior citizens people
with comorbidities compromised immune
systems and a nursing home is a
aggregation of those people and that's
how it started and that is where it is
most dangerous in the nursing homes I
understand that I understand the nursing
home staff has been doing doing the
people who staff these nursing homes
have been doing a fantastic job because
it really is very difficult and we had
to put some precautions in place that
are just so harsh I mean we can't have
we said no visitors to a nursing home
during this entire time I mean just
think how harsh that is right but all it
takes is one person to walk into that
nursing home with a virus and then
you're off to the races so we're doing
everything we can the nursing homes are
working very hard we also announced an
investigation with the Attorney General
and the Department of Health to make
sure the nursing homes are doing what
they need to do many of them are
privately run but this state can
regulate them they have to notify
families etc so we're doing an
investigation on that but remember the
basic premise of the nursing home the
nursing home can only accept or keep a
patient if if they can provide adequate
care for that patient if they have a
kovat patient or non kovat patient but
they can't provide adequate care for
that person it is their obligation to
transfer the person if they can't find
the place to transfer the person it's
their obligation to call the State
Department of Health and the State
Department of Health will transfer the
person we have facilities
for kovat nursing home residents we have
some facilities that are just Fork Ovid
positive nursing home residents so we
have those facilities available if a
nursing home can't care for a co vyd
resident called the Department of Health
the Department of Health will transfer
the patient period and that
responsibility is on the nursing home
they have to know who they can care for
and who they can't care for if they
can't care for them for any reason my
staff is out sick I don't have the PPE
I can't quarantine I can't isolate for
whatever reason they have an obligation
to call the State Department of Health
and say I have to transfer this person
and we have existing facilities and beds
for them but the nursing home has to
make that determination and if they are
caring for people or they have people
who they're not suited to care for then
they're violating the state policy and
that's part of what this investigation
is going to look at so I've set the
nursing homes before I say it again if
you cannot provide adequate care then
that person has no business being in
your nursing home and we do have
facilities and we do have beds that can
care for nursing home residents and do
it well and do it safely last point I'd
like to make the today we're talking
about what local government officials
have to do what each region has to do to
be ready May 15th is a possible
reopening if you're ready this is how
you're ready learning from the lessons
on the science on the facts but this is
a situation where yes government is
first and foremost in a position where
they have to make decisions and perform
and do it well and competence matters
and professionalism matters and will
hold government officials accountable
I want to be held accountable hold
government officials accountable but we
also need local officials we need our
hospital administrators to be a big part
of this and we need every citizen to be
part of this you know who's going to
keep you safe
you are you are not me you are by your
actions you know who's going to keep
your family safe your family and you are
by being responsible and reasonable in
this situation and then you know how we
keep each other safe by our individual
responsibility and respect by wearing
the mask by maintaining the social
distancing that's how we get through
this everybody has a role to play here
there is no pointing fingers nobody's
been here before it's no one else's job
it's all of us together and that's what
has worked so well so far we just have
to stay at it it's been an honor to be
with you thank you very much
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm seeing everything whole families of
people work mom grandma kids
everyone's positive police officers
coming needing to get tested I can't get
tests at work
there's a huge need for us here we are
at one of the harder hit